hallo leute wir sind heute in berlin
draußen ist es traurig trist grau
regnerisch aber das zeigen wir euch
heute nicht denn wir zeigen euch heute
unseren kühlschrank für deutsche größen
ist das ein großer kühlschrank werde ich
sogar sagen wir haben hier ein kühlfach
das kühlfach und hier ein gefrierfach
dass die vierfach anschlägen noch eine
ganz besondere tradition wir sammeln
nämlich magnete auf unserem kühlschrank
machen ja viele menschen aber wir machen
das von unseren reisen
hier haben wir zum beispiel hanoi in
vietnam und das hier ist mein lieblings
magnet putin 2012
den habe ich 2008 in sankt petersburg
erstanden
was ist dein lieblings magnet der tiere
der bbi-eröffnung welcher ach so der aus
mexiko kommen wir am flughafen gekauft
damit öffnet janisch sein bier wir
öffnen jetzt unseren kühlschrank für
euch exklusiv seht ihr was wir hier drin
haben wir haben getränke und essen
logischerweise an getränken haben wir
voll milch die trink janisch und
meistens haben wir ungefähr sechs oder
sieben haltbare vollmilch die kal sind
denn janesch trinkt viel kaffee mit viel
milch dann haben wir typisch deutsch
apfelschorle kann ich eigentlich auch
wieder zurückstellen tonic für gin tonic
und ich trinke keine normale milch ich
trinke cashew mich das witzige ist das
ja tatsächlich unsere eigenen fächer
haben das hier ist ja und das ist mein
fach und das ist eine komische tradition
oder janisch nein das ist eine bequeme
reduzieren ein bisschen komisch ist die
schon seid ihr auch ein pärchen dann
möchten wir gerne von euch will
habt ihr auch getrennte fächer im
kühlschrank oder wirft ihr alles
durcheinander zeigen wir mal was janisch
im kühlschrank hat ja es hat immer im
kühlschrank ein gurkenglas denn er liebt
gurken er kommt ja aus polen
deswegen hat er meistens mehrere
gurkengläser im kühlschrank
was sagst du zu deinen gurken ja lecker
aber nicht so lecker wie die polnischen
die polnischen fehlen gesetzlich dann
hat ja muss immer im kühlschrank butter
mutter braucht man zum brot war ja auch
aus polen kommt in polen und in
deutschland essen wir viel brot also es
gibt immer brot butter und aufschnitt im
kühlschrank käse schinken immer hat ja
na ja denn eier ist er auch jeden tag
oder erfasst und das was ich am liebsten
mag bayerisch im fach ist der stinkt
käse noch mehr käse ja eine stunde ist
drei käse soll vier käsesorten ist das
normal
ja das ist lecker
ich habe immer kalt bei mir wasser mit
kohlensäure sprudelwasser dann habe ich
hier ja noch kommen
ja ich wissen was da drin ist eine alte
ausgequetscht zitrone hält die habe ich
einfach die firma wieder zurück außerdem
hat ja auch immer da quark und
erdbeermarmelade die erwärmung lage ist
wichtig denn ja es ist sehr viel abwärme
lade und ich habe hier unten meine
eigene erdbeermarmelade wir essen die
gleiche marmelade aber wir haben immer
zwei milliarden rallye amish der
verschlingt die immer die
erdbeermarmelade das heißt ich kaufe so
eine so ein glas stellt das in den
kühlschrank benutzt das einmal und drei
tage später ist das lehr- und dann sage
ich ja so geht das nicht du musst du
deine eigene marmelade kaufen möchtest
du dazu stellung beziehen
ja deutschland kennen und kaum werden
ich oder was die marmelade was habe ich
noch ich esse joghurt aus lupinen und in
die joghurt durch himbeeren blaubeeren
noch mehr himbeeren ein süß
kartoffeleintopf was ist das denn ja das
ist meine wurst die kann glaube ich weg
und heute abend zum abendessen gibt es
bei schmidts kies rostbratwurst bio
rostbratwurst von rewe mit persona vokal
mit feldsalat und dazu gibt es dann noch
tomaten und sonstige sachen die sind
jetzt nicht im kühlschrank
hier haben wir drei gefrier fächer oben
sind eiswürfel
auch typisch deutsch
maultaschen das ist man so im
schwäbischen raum ist übrigens eine
schöne aussprache übung auf deutsch
ihr könnt einfach zehnmal hintereinander
gefrierfach sagen das gefrierfach
gefrierfach gefrierfach gefrierfach
gefrierfach gefrier fächer okay das war
unser kühlschrank ihr könnt uns jetzt
eure fragen zum kühlschrank hier unten
schreiben wir hoffen ihr habt ein paar
neue vokabeln gelernt und wir freuen uns
eure kommentare zu lesen zum kühlschrank
wie sieht das bei euch zu hause aus
liebe grüße und bis bald
[Musik]